كانت روسيا شنت قصفا مكثفا على مناطق
اوكرانيه ردا على توغل في الاراضي الروسيه
نسبته الى مخربين من اوكرانيا وهو امر طرح
تساؤلات حول اسباب استخدام موسكو لهذا
النوع من الصواريخ وسبل مواجهتها
او الخنجر باللغه الروسيه هي صواريخ
باليستيه فرط صوتيه هذا الطراز يصعب
التصدي له بشكل كبير لان انظمه الدفاع
الجوي تعجز اصلا عن رصده يعد كينجنال
البديل الذي يتم اطلاقه من الجو من صاروخ
الكسندر البالستي قصير المدى والذي تم
استخدامه ايضا بشكل متكرر في اوكرانيا
صواريخ كنجال من نوعيه جو ارض تعمل ضد
الاهداف البحريه والارضيه على حد سواء
وبسرعه عاليه تفوق الصواريخ المضاده وتفوق
القدره على المناوره على مستويات منخفضه
لتجنبها
ثانيا الاخباريه الامريكيه رات ان العوده
لاستخدام هذه النوعيه من الصواريخ وبهذه
الكثافه من قبل روسيا يحمل ردا من موسكو
على التقارير حول استنفار قدراتها
العسكريه مع طول فتره الحرب كما انه يمثل
رساله لدول الاوروبيه بان موسكو قادره على
استهداف البناء التحتيه بسهوله خاصه وان
عمليه التسليح الغربيه تتواصل لكياب رغم
التحذيرات الروسيه المتكرره